Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call. And remember to
everybody as you enter, you're muted. So, if you have a question, use the chat box and
you can chat in a question. Otherwise, if you have asked a question,
on the member site, it should be already on here. So let's jump into the questions we had. We don't have
a ton of questions today. So, if you want this to go a little longer, make sure you think of a question
and get it chatted in. First question. What are some best ways to deal with stress? So,
that's a good question. We all have stress. Certainly, when we get cancer diagnosis,
it's a cause of stress, you know, dealing with other people in a cause of stress, dealing with work
issues could be a cause of stress. So, there's lots of causes of stress. So, always, when you're
dealing with anything, you want to try to do your best to mitigate the cause. So, if the cause of
my stress is, you know, an unhappy relationship, try to work on that relationship because of your
stresses, too much work at the office, try to deal with that, talk to your boss or whatever. You
know, you try to get to the cause, always, when you're dealing with anything. So, not just your health
issues, you're trying to deal with causative factors. That's going to be the best way to deal with it.
So, let's say you've done all of that, but it's just this inner angst, this inner stress in my body.
I just feel fatigued. You might have symptoms of adrenal burnout or adrenal fatigue.
What are some ways to deal with it? Well, from a nutritional standpoint, diet is really important.
So, if, you know, you're eating foods that are highly inflammatory, that's going to make it worse.
We tend to crave sweets and salty things when our aderitos are fatigued. So, that is,
you know, one of the signs of adrenal fatigue is craving salty foods. That's not the only reason
why you would crave salty foods, but it is a sign. So, dealing with inflammatory causes in our
diet, typically like food sensitivities and things to calm down the inflammation that could be going
in our gut. That could help. From a nutritional nutraceutical standpoint, taking adaptogenic herbs
that could help balance your hormones, that could help. If you're interested in doing objective
testing with stress, getting the Dutch test done, looks at all your hormones, including cortisol,
curve. So, your tested cortisol levels four times during the day, it should have a nice
certain looking curve should be normal, and you want to measure that so you can see
if there is an issue with your adrenal hormones at all, it can be other hormones that can be
causing it too. So, those are the first things I think of. If you're thinking of what is a
supplement that I could do, take to help with stress, anti-inflammatories like curcumid,
it goes well, you know, things like that, and then adaptogens are the most common thing that you'd
use for helping with stress to help balance your hormones. Next question.
Last week, you said you weren't a fan of black pepper because it makes everything in your gut
absorb better. Is this the same thing? Is the same thing true of red hot peppers or hot red pepper flakes?
No, no. So, it was discovered years ago that black pepper helped you absorb different nutrients. So,
they actually started putting black pepper because take a step back. Many nutrients in the
nutraceutical industry over the years have been discovered to be great for certain things,
but the problem was the form of that nutrient that was available at the time, many times with
many of the different nutrients, was not really well absorbed. Let's use like glutathione as an example.
Probably about 15 years ago, the form of glutathione that we used with patients, not with our
cancer patients, forever, but what we used with the like fibromyalgia and autoimmune patients and
things, was not readily absorbed. So, we used to create, in our clinic, we used to make our own
laposomal glutathione for the sake of absorbability. Are we used to have people devilize glutathione
dissolve it in a liquid water and then devilize it in order to increase the absorption? Well, then
over time, they started increasing the, you know, better eat the product itself with different
testing and absorbability of different nutrients and, you know, glutathione in our example has gone
through multiple different changes in the product, multiple endpoint product that is distributed
and sold. And now, glutathione, even in L, glutathione is much more absorbable. Now, they also have
laposomal glutathione things. So, it's much more absorbable. But during this time, they found that
black pepper helped things absorb it. One of the studies was done uncurcumulated black pepper
that it really increased absorbability. So, a lot of companies added black pepper to their
curcumin. And I'm not against using black pepper in your curcumin. But if you're adding black pepper
to a lot of different supplements that you're taking, you will increase the absorbability of other
things that are in the gut. Maybe things you don't want to absorb. So, you have to be careful with that.
So, but that is not true with hot pepper, cayenne pepper and red pepper flakes, so you're safe with
those. Next question. My last MRI two weeks ago showed a much increase in cancer in the spine.
What is your best recommendation for this? So, remember, if you have, let's say you have breast
cancer in a metastasized to your spine, it's still breast cancer. It's not bone cancer,
spine cancer, or something like that. So, the treatment as far as what you're doing specifically to
try to kill the cancer, whether you're doing, you know, you name it, there's 100 different
nutraceutical type treatments, or you're doing chemotherapy, or you're doing immunotherapy,
is really not going to change just because it metastasized, regardless of whether metastasized
to the spine or something else. Now, there may be something that you would do to help support the
loss of bone if it metastasized to bone. So, if cancer metastasized to bone, it's going to be what's
called osteolytic. I mean, it's going to cause bony destruction. So, it's going to eat away the
bone and destroy the bone. Well, when that happens, if weakens the bone and bone serves as, you know,
a source of nutrients, a source of minerals to the body, your bones are very living. They're not
just dead structures that just support you physically, but there's calcium minerals going in and out
of bone all the time. You have osteolytic and osteoclastic activity in bone all the time,
but when you have this excessive osteolytic lesion that's going on with bony metastasized, you're
losing bone and, you know, you're losing those minerals and one of the main minerals of bone that
gives it structure in the inner part of the bone called the endosteum is calcium. So, if it is in a
weight-bearing bone, which the spine is, so the spine, certain bones are weight-bearing bones
and certain bones aren't weight-bearing bones. Your fingers aren't weight-bearing bones. They're not
holding you up physically. Your spine is. So, if you lose too much mass, too much of the density of
the bone in, let's say, the vertebral body, which is the part of the spine that is weight-bearing,
you could have what's called a pathological fracture or collapse of the vertebral body
and, you know, that it's going to pinch the nerves and the pressure on the cord and could give you
all sorts of different problems. So, you do want to try to, you know, add nutrients to increase the
strength of the spine. So, taking a good source of minerals like, like, reacted minerals are
clear multibits and the best source of calcium is the osteo-k product. It's called osteo-k.
It's the correct form of MK4. Most of the K's, the vitamin K's out there are going to be MK7.
You need MK4 and extremely high dose to get calcium into the bone and osteo-k is the only
no supplement I know that has that. So, osteo-k would be something that I recommend,
and plus taking other minerals as well. Second part of the question, it was also ER positive years ago
so they assume that it still is estrogen receptor positive. And should I get a change in my
rife programs and should I try to keep the ball near my spine after time? Press cancer was the
main diagnosis, liver lungs, and have had some issues too. So, yeah, if the closer you could
keep it to the site, the better, and do you need to change the rife program? No, as I stated before,
it's still breast cancer, it's not bone cancer, so the programming should stay the same. Next question.
A blood work shows red blood cells are lower near anemia. Is the solution to take iron,
supplement, or are there other ways to treat anemia that is with the rife fishy?
The good news is that two weeks on the nightly rife by white blood cell count went from 143 to 18,
or the past, it was rapidly trending upwards since this person has a blood cancer,
and they have elevated white blood cell count. So, everybody here knows that your white blood cell
count should be about 4 to 6.5. So, this elevated white blood cell count is a blood cancer.
So, what do you do with red blood cells that are low? So, you have anemia, you have low red blood
cells, probably elevated MCV, MCHC, RDW, so you have other signs of anemia, plus low red blood
cell count. Can you take iron for that? So, it partly depends upon the cancer, and it partly depends
upon how anemic a person is. If you're just near anemia, but you're still within normal range,
if somebody has a solid tumor cancer, I would say no, let's be careful not to give iron.
By solid tumor cancer, I mean like breast cancer, liver cancer, colon cancer,
not a leukemia or multiple myeloma. So, the leukemias, multiple myeloma, and even sub lymphomas,
you could readily use iron. The reason why I say that is if you have a solid tumor cancer,
like breast cancer, colon cancer, prostate cancer, etc., giving iron to that, even in the case of
a person having anemia, if you give iron, iron can actually feed the cancer. That doesn't typically
take place, almost never takes place with the blood cancer. So, the leukemias and lymphomas,
typically you don't have to worry so much about that at all. And you could treat the anemia with
iron. But I would want to see your labs because just because you have low red blood cells,
doesn't mean that it's necessarily iron deficiency anemia. It could be B12 anemia, it could be B6
anemia, it could be folate anemia. There's multiple different types of anemia in you.
You discover that by looking at the other values. So, the RDW, MCV, MCHC, and some other things you
want to look at in the CBC. So, that's what we would want to look at to really see, should we give
this person iron? Because there's some rules in my book at least, you could have low red blood cells,
oh, I have dear anemia, but your ferritid is super high. That you never give iron to somebody who's
got high ferritid. So, we want to look at the rest of the blood work before we say, oh, you have anemia,
let's low red blood cells, dear anemia, let's just assume it's iron deficiency anemia and let's just
assume that you're okay to take it because your ferritid is normal. We need to look at that and be
more specific, but that's a great question. Next question, is the BAM taken twice a day like the other
powder drinks to add into the drink mixes or just once? So, the BAM for those who don't know what that
is, which is most people on here don't know what it is, it's a product that we've created that I named
it BAM as brain anti-inflammatory mix. That's what I named it so. But in truth, it's not just for
the brain, but actually I created it with that in mind. So, there's a bunch of anti-inflammatory
nutrients in BAM, and it's a powder just like our medicinal mushroom mix, but it has different
things in it. So, BAM is anti-inflammatory for everything in your body, but I specifically created it
for the brain, and should you take it twice a day with the other powders? I would say yes, take it twice
a day. The truth is, you can't really own D on BAM at all, and so, yeah, taking it more often would be
better, and you'd get more benefits from it. Then you go over COVID supplementation, recommendations
that folks should have on hand. So, I'm not exactly sure if you're asking. So, things to prevent COVID
or other possible pathogens or viruses or bacteria that could be coming down the road,
I would answer that this way. So, we have a product called ClearCV that was created specifically for
this. We created it during COVID, and it has the things, you know, zinc, vitamin C, vitamin A,
etcetera, that are just a great blend to help prevent viral issues if you're afraid of getting a
virus. So, that was why we created it during COVID when people were afraid of going to the store and
getting infected with a virus. So, ClearCV is the name of it, and it stands for
what is it for cold and virus or something like that? Or COVID? I don't know. Well, we couldn't say COVID
on the label, so we just called it ClearCV. Now, it isn't specific to any one virus, and it's not
even specific to viruses, it would be more anti-pathogen to prevent infections. Now, what would happen if
I got sick if I wanted some recommendations to have on hand for my family if we got ill? Well,
that would depend on what it is. So, if it's viral or if it's bacterial, that would be a little bit
different, but we have some different immune supplements that would be, you know, for either one,
aloevia immune would be a great supplement that's a polysaccharide in a specific form that has been
shown with research to really boost T cells and natural killer cells, so it's great for cancer,
but it's also great for bacteria and viruses, too. There's different herbs that would be really good
for any certain bacteria and cancers, garlic, oregano, acnecia that are really good for
different conditions. Now, that being said, the caveat to that is if you have a known autoimmune
disease, then you have to be careful not to take immune stimulants on a regular basis as a
preventative, because you'd be up-regulated, your immune system, and if you haven't have antibodies
to neural tissue, let's say the brain tissue, then you could be, you know, causing more destruction
on a daily basis of that neural tissue that you have antibodies against, because when you
up-regulate your immune system, you're going to kill that which you have antibodies against first,
which is your own tissue if you have an autoimmune disease. Now, if you have cancer, you've got to
kind of throw that out and we've got to up-regulate our immune system because we've got to kill the cancer,
but you have to weigh that out and let's say you don't have cancer, your family doesn't have cancer,
but my wife has, you know, Hashimoto's thyroid, should she be taking clear CV on a daily basis? I would
say no, probably not, but if you feel like you're exposed to something, you feel like you're coming
down to something in an acute situation, you can certainly take immune stimulants. Question from the
chat, I do coffee enemas once a day for years with my first cancer in 2004. I did two a day
the Gonzalez Protocol. No, I have CLL, which is chronic lymphocytic leukemia.
Should I increase the coffee enemas to two a day? Well, partly that depends on how you're doing,
and you know, if you feel like you're stable and you're doing well, then I would say no, if you feel
like you're trendy in a little bit in the wrong direction, then I would say yes. So I'm just going to
kind of go back to what Max Gerson used to talk about coffee enemas. That's the way he would have
people, and I followed his recommendations in this matter, he would have people do up to five coffee
enemas a day if they were doing poorly. And the whole purpose of that, remember the purpose of the
coffee enemas is to stimulate parasympathetics thereby stimulating the liver to help detoxify,
and stimulating the gut to help detoxify, and you're going to help stimulate parastosis by stimulating
parasympathetics. And you're going to help stimulate the immune response when you stimulate parasympathetics,
and you're going to help calm your body and calm your emotions when you stimulate parasympathetics,
because your parasympathetic response is a call made response. You'll also open up the vessels,
you'll decrease blood pressure, there's all these benefits of a parasympathetic response.
That's the whole purpose of doing coffee animals. But of course they take time and they're not
super fun to do and you know you're trying to live your life so you have to have this balance. So
he would and I have over all these years have said you know if you're doing better you couldn't
trim down the coffee animals. When I was doing poorly I was doing coffee animals on a daily basis
but I rarely did more than one just because I was still working but it but now I don't I have
another coffee animal for a while. So it's the use of coffee animals is based upon the frequency of
coffee animals I should say is based upon you know where you're at how well you're doing
and guide it that way. But you could do anywhere from one only a week to one a day to
five a day depending on those factors and it didn't change my picture for last week. Any other questions
well this is the shortest zoom call we've had in about five years. It's such a beautiful day hopefully
everybody's outside enjoying the weather. How highly do you recommend the whole house EFF
product you sell? Well there's different whole house EFF products that we sell. There's one
that you connect electrically you have to get an electrician to connect it to your box that will help
block dirty electricity in your house. That one it's the ones serve different purposes.
So that one I think is a better product. He drugs sells a whole house disc and of course it depends
on bigger houses obviously to help block let's take that back. He drugs disc don't block EFFs
they mitigate EFFs so they help change it to a calmer form so it's not dangerous to your body.
That's the heat rod is the same company that makes the small little ones that you stick on your phone.
Are those great? I think they're great yes so they're great units. How beneficial are they?
That's another question there's just it's an impossible you know if you want to be objective about
everything it's very hard to objectify that. The unit that connects to the house to clean dirty
electricity that's easy to objectify because there's data that how that works. We have one
connected to our house I think they're extremely beneficial it's they actually pay for themselves
in electricity that you'll actually save throughout the year too. So I think those are more I think
those are more beneficial than the hedron discs. And partly it's that if you get the hedron
disc it's like nobody has ever said to me oh my gosh I feel so much better having that thing
but I have had people say they feel better with either the plug-in units or the whole house unit
that blocks dirty electricity so I would say the whole house unit that blocks dirty electricity
are better. Let's say no next question do you need to replace the hedron harmonizer on your phone
from time to time. Technically they say no you don't I mean if it's damaged just because it's like
beats to the pulp then maybe you think that might be a good idea but technically they say no you don't
so they're a good value I think and I think you know for the most part people are changing their phones
as often as they use to I don't know maybe I'm not an iPhone user I am a Samsung and I have had
this phone for three four five years or so maybe iPhone users have to change your phones a little bit
more often but it's hard sometimes to get them off and to get them to stick on a new phone
that's why I mentioned that but I don't I think that as long as they're in good shape I don't think
you need to change them okay with that we will say goodbye thanks for being on everybody
the blessed afternoon enjoy the weather hopefully everybody has good weather where you're at
and we'll be praying for you bye